we've got some news to report right now
and it's about Congressman Steve Scalise
he is doing great in his recovery maybe
you remember it was just about three and
a half months ago that the Republican
majority whip was shot during the
Congressional baseball practice remember
we covered it live here on the air well
on Sunday on 60 minutes he will talk for
the first time since the tragedy the
House Majority Whip agreed to help us
piece together what exactly happened on
that day in June and his road to
recovery Scalise was shot in the hip the
bullet lodged inside of him that never
exited it caused heavy internal bleeding
we also talked to his wife and the
doctors that helped saved his life it's
an incredible story as he has been in
the hospital ever since you can see the
interview Sunday on 60 minutes here on
CBS forward to that he was in a lot
worse shape than many of us realized
wasn't he nor he he barely survived he
was barely alive when he made it to the
hospital and he had multiple and
infections so it's been a long road to
recovering since it seemed upright but
he doing much better now
yeah he's doing much better and he'll
walk us through his recovery and what he
calls the many miracles that saved his
life